l'opposant russe alexeï navalni présente
des traces d'empoisonnement selon
l'hôpital allemand où il a été admis
dans le coma une version qui contredit
celle des médecins qui l'ont examiné en
russie à l'instant on apprend qu angela
merkel la chancelière allemande appelle
la russie à punir les coupables ont fait
le point depuis moscou avec notre
correspondant antoine claireaux bonsoir
antoine alors qu'on a découvert exact
qu'on découvert exactement les médecins
allemands mais à l'hôpital berlinois
dans lequel a été prise en charge avec
ses 9 ali a publié dans l'après-midi un
communiqué qui évoque la présence dans
son organisme d'une substance toxique
est une substance de la famille des
inhibiteurs de la colline aux terrasses
qui s'attaque au système nerveux alors
la substance en elle-même n'a pas encore
été identifié les analyses continue
cependant d'après les médecins allemands
des séquelles à long terme ne peuvent
être exclus à ce stade plus tôt dans la
journée déjà le gouvernement allemand
avait fait savoir qu'il jugeait d'assez
probable la thèse de l'empoisonnement
intentionnel je posais d'écouter le
porte-parole du gouvernement allemand le
soupçon ne porte pas sur le fait que
monsieur n'à vanille s'est gravement
empoisonnés lui-même mais sur le fait
que quelqu'un est gravement empoisonnés
monsieur n'à vanille et malheureusement
il existe un ou deux exemples de ce
genre dans l'histoire récente de la
russie
c'est pourquoi je pense que le monde
entier prend ce soupçon très au sérieux
mais voilà ces conclusions de l'hôpital
allemand viennent contredire les
déclarations tenues pas plus tard que ce
matin par le directeur de l'hôpital
d'omsk dans lequel a été prise en charge
alexeï navalni dans un premier temps à
écouter le diagnostic d'empoisonnement a
été maintenu jusqu'à la fin de la
journée jusqu'à minuit si je ne
pas nous avons alors reçu la conclusion
finale de deux laboratoires à tomsk et à
moscou qu'aucun produit chimique toxique
pouvant être considéré comme un poison
ou un dérivé de poison n'a été trouvé
depuis le ministère de la santé d'omsk a
proposé de communiquer à l'hôpital de
berlin l'ensemble des résultats des
analyses menées par les médecins russes
et ce ne sera pas de trop pour répondre
aux questions encore nombreuse qui
continue de planer sur cette affaire
merci antoine claireaux en direct de
moscou